hey guys I'm just stalling for a minute
or so till everyone logs on and if you
wouldn't mind just letting my letting me
know if you can hear me that would be
great
can you hear me give that worse Oh
awesome
Oh some people are saying no a lot of
people are saying yes and no so my mic
shows that I'm not so you should be able
to hear me
and worst case scenario if you can't
hear me what I will do is out this is
pre-recorded so not pre-recorded but
it's recorded so we'll upload it and you
can watch it tomorrow okay I think we're
good
good I'm just going to give it a couple
more minutes
I'm just playing around with these
buttons here as people logging on we
have about 2500 attendees today and for
some reason I have steps I saw this new
button says request so I'm going to
upload this is invite as a speaker so
I'm just going to press it and see if I
can invite some my attendees as speakers
so if you get an invitation we'll see
what happens maybe I could pop you in
and we can talk to you we'll see if that
works okay let's give about 30 more
seconds all right
oh cool that worked Judy yes
hey Judy I just pulled you right into my
webinar here so maybe you could help me
up you can ask any questions as we go
through this okay okay thank you
sometimes it's a little difficult to do
a seminar by yourself because you can't
see anyone but at least I see one person
so there's some other people here too
and I'm going to invite in alright okay
so welcome to the webinar everyone we're
going to get started this is a very
vital webinar it's on fat burning and
exactly how fat burning works so you
might want to take some notes you're
going to have a lot of questions I will
be more than happy to answer the
questions that you have as we go but I'm
trying to make them brief it looks like
Judy Judy could you mute your microphone
for a little bit until I pop you in cool
ok so everyone's everyone's able to do
you know that you might be because
there's so many people I don't know if
it's going to affect the pausing or not
but let's let's get started so a lot of
you got my emails on a recent webinar on
ketosis I want to really want to cover
that in depth it's a little bit complex
but I'm going to make it as simple as
possible then I'll answer any questions
that you have I've been doing ketosis
for a quite a while and I use it on
clients that have tried everything and
nothing's worked
because a lot of people are carb
sensitive and I want to get into the
difference between paleo and ketosis so
there's some big differences and I also
want to get into what do you
each long-term and but I think the
biggest thing that comes up is the
problem is that it's a red flag our fats
eating fats okay to eat are they
dangerous to eat I want to cover that as
well I think the worst recommendation
that we've ever heard was the concept of
everything in moderation because it
allows everything in moderation of
balance which you'll never get into fat
burning if you do that so that is the
worst advice to tell someone you have a
balanced diet because that doesn't work
now some of the anti ketosis
practitioners out there almost
everything one of them have never
practiced before an actual clinical
setting they might do research on rats
but they don't actually practice so when
you work with actual people over and
over and over over years and years you
will find that the whole calorie in
calorie out model does not work eating
less calories and you're burning does
not work so you have to think outside
the box I would I am totally convinced
that the majority of information being
put out by conventional means is the
exact opposite of what you want to do
and I can prove that and it just happens
over and over and over so I'm going to
pull up some slides see if I could do a
screen share here ok hopefully I can do
my screen share
and all these slides don't tell me that
I can't pull Phi hmm well that's not
good okay hang in there for a second hmm
let's see if I can do my screen share
why isn't that working I have this all
these great presa slides that I want to
cover okay well we're just going to keep
going here I'm just going to we're going
to have to just describe some of these
slides but the first question I want to
talk about is is ketosis safe is it
healthy I really think it's one of the
healthiest things that you can do
there's some serious research being done
or has been done on ketosis for all
sorts of things probably the biggest
thing is for brain and neuro protection
of your brain Alzheimer's Parkinson's
seizures things like that so the brain
loves this type of fuel called ketones
which we'll get into describing what
that is but the state of ketosis is very
good for any type of blood sugar issues
diabetes heart related issues
neurological cancer and the reason why
it's good for cancer is because the
cancer cell lives on sugar PET scans
basically scan the body for a certain
posture body that are eating up a lot of
sugar so the cancer cell loves sugar and
if I had cancer I would completely
utterly limonade all my sugars and I
would have a much better chance of
surviving respiratory issues asthma
allergies acne polycystic ovarian
syndrome and especially weight loss so
those are some of the health benefits
I'm going to probably send everyone
access to the slides so you can get all
the slides because I have research
studies if you want to look at an
especially ones in cardiovascular that
basically state that when you consume
dietary saturated fats it does not in
any way shape or form increase risk of
cardiovascular accidents or card heart
attacks so that's pretty powerful stuff
because that goes exactly against what
we've been brainwashed to think it's
very good for a cognitive function brain
function
and and I'll have to kind of describe
these some of these images that we're
talking about so when we're dealing with
excess stubborn fat we're dealing with a
problem of stuck energy in the fat cell
that is the biggest problem that we have
and so I want to move beyond the
conventional viewpoint that all you have
to do is balance your calories and eat
less than your you know burning and
you'll lose weight that's absolutely not
true maybe if you're 18 years old but
when you get 20 30 40 you don't you know
it doesn't work anymore so there's
really two fuel sources you have the
sugar fuel and we have the fat fuel fat
fuel really you can only tap into that
when you're in ketosis ketosis is a
condition that the body is burning fat
and it's actually using ketones as a
byproduct of fat burning so ketones are
a fuel source that's very similar in
function to glucose but it's a much
cleaner fuel it has 3 times as much
energy as glucose and the problem with
running on glucose or sugar is that you
get high blood pressure bigger and you
get low blood sugar the only the total
amount of sugar in your blood is is
basically two teaspoons that's it so if
you ever get your blood tested and they
say you have diabetes whatever or you
don't have let diabetes so we're going
to look at these these numbers if you're
higher than a hundred its hyperglycemia
or diabetes if it's lower than 100 it's
hypoglycemia so you want to be 100 and
what that 100 means is two teaspoons of
sugar in your blood at any one time as
you do ketosis the blood sugars will
come down a little bit but it won't
create a hypoglycemic state but a lot of
people oscillate from high sugars to low
sugars all day long so this can anyone
tell me what are some of the symptoms of
high blood sugar can you tell me
and what that 100 means is two teaspoons
of sugar
well I just clicked on a button that
about someone sent me I shouldn't have
done that
can anyone tell me just go ahead and
type in what symptoms do you get when
you get high sugar in your blood okay
very good you get brain fog you get
tired blurred vision you get thirsty
that's right
cold sweats very good so those are some
of the symptoms with a hyper glycaemia
so basically thirsty need to urinate
often dry skin hungry blurred vision
fatigue brain fog okay
that's with high sugar all right now
what are the symptoms with low blood
sugar does anyone know it's called
hypoglycemia
very good that's right shaky sweating
dizziness anxiety irritability psychosis
craving for sugar vision problems weak
so they really affect your cognitive
function so anytime that sugar goes high
or low it just messes with your physical
and mental capacities and so that's why
running on ketosis is very therapeutic
for your mood for your sense of calmness
for your overall stress because that
brain is very greedy it basically sucks
up it's only 2% of your whole body but
it sucks up 20% of the energy so it's
constantly wanting that sugar so you'll
probably hear from some people that the
brain only runs on sugar well it only
runs on sugar until you don't give it
sugar ok then it can switch to ketosis
so what happens is that your body will
not feed the brain ketones unless
there's no sugar in the bloodstream ok
so it does convert now here's the thing
you have a storage of sugar and your
sugar is mainly stored in the liver and
the muscles so let's talk about the
muscles first the muscle has the stored
sugar but it only is used for the
muscles the muscle will not give up any
of its stores sugar to the rest of the
body it will keep it self contained so
you really can't use the stored sugar
for your muscles at all it's there to
feed your muscles as an own like as a
soil purpose so now we're left with the
liver so the liver is storing about 7
tablespoons of sugar enough to last for
about 72 hours ok if you ate nothing or
no sugar you would be dead in 72 hours
unless there was a backup fuel system ok
and that's your fat so
one thing that's cool about this eating
plan is that it really fixes a lot of
symptoms that people have with their
cognitive function with memory with
their mood with anxiety because when
those sugars come up and down up and
down and you're craving and you're
hungry oh my gosh that is not the way to
to live in fact there's even a stage 3
type 3 diabetes which affects the brain
or memory ok so here's the thing I
better just kind of define what I mean
by diabetes there's two types types one
is where you don't have enough insulin
from that pancreas and so the sugar goes
higher and higher because the purpose of
insulin is to control sugars by lowering
sugars storing in the fat the type 2 is
that the insulin is being produced but
it's not being received into the
receptors into the liver so it's not
being listened to so it's another
problem with storage of sugar
I'm sorry insulin so then that what
happens is the sugars go high because
the insulin is there but it's not
available to the cells okay so they're
both a similar problem but one's more
advanced I'm getting some interesting
comments here that um people feel great
and then there's a lot of weight when
I'm ketosis okay that's awesome so again
I will send all of you these slides okay
I will just send those because I have
your emails so here's here's the thing
unless you know you're you don't have
any stored sugar for over 72 hours
unless you have a good amount of fat
reserves and you know how to do this you
won't be able to tap into fat so here's
here's the big question then I'm going
to see if you guys can get this right um
this anyone know if what the purpose of
fat is can anyone tell me let's see if
anyone can get it correct this is a key
question let's see if anyone knows the
purpose
of fat and Judy once you put on your mic
I can see your top of your head Judy um
what's what's the purpose of fat over
there um to protect yourself very close
it's definitely to protect something but
a lot of people say it's like a cushion
or an insulator and that type of thing
yeah yeah well that's not the primary
purpose but thank you for answering that
so if you can put your thing back on
mute and I'll come back here a second
all right so thank you energy storage
Energy's protective fuel energy Wow when
you're doing a seminar this big you have
a lot of answers that scroll pretty fast
very good storage of energy okay so I
have not seen one person get this
correct no yeah and this leads me to my
point the biggest misunderstood word or
subject is is basically what the purpose
of fat is here's the primary purpose of
fat you guys ready for this I don't
think you're quite ready maybe we'll
have to do this next next month Julie
what do you think now I'm just kidding
we're going to do it I'm just playing
with you okay this is the purpose of fat
it's a survival gland that protects
against the starvation of what does
anyone know sugar
let me say that again fats primary
purpose is to protect against the
starvation of sugar it protects you
against sugar starvation what does that
mean that means that fat is a backup
organ to sugar okay so it backs up
storage
it's a backup to sugar so it's really
because you wouldn't last for more than
72 hours or less your brain your body is
it gains fat in case it needs to do that
so what does this tell us
what how does this relate to what we
have to do to get this fat off our
bodies well it means that you have to
starve your body of sugar so most of you
already have done this some of you are
trying to do this a lot of people have
questions so basically the most
important thing to know is that it's a
back up organ to sugar so now knowing
this data will now tell you what tie it
would be best to be on right and if we
if we look at this compared to the
conventional reduce your calories and
exercise more well yeah you're going to
reduce your calories but according to
the government you're still going to
consume 65 percent of your calories of
carbohydrates you will never tap into
your fat weight watchers' a lot of
slimfast you're never going to burn fat
now because you're low in calories you
might lose water weight but I'll
guarantee you're not going to lose much
fat so here's the most important thing
we must starve the body sugar okay so
that's the bad news the good news is we
can replace it with more healthy fats
which is going to be very satisfying to
your body so
get into exactly what that means in a
bit but we must bring down the
carbohydrates to about five percent of
our overall calories which comes out to
about no more than 50 grams of net carbs
high drain okay now hey Judy
can you pop your mic back on um
okay good Judy tell me um do you do you
know that net carbohydrate is not really
okay it's very very simple you basically
look on the back of the label and you
get the total carbohydrates and you -
the fiber carbohydrates I'm sorry for
the fiber okay so you - that alright so
thank you for for answering me there you
can put it back on mute so yeah we just
take the total carbohydrates and we -
the dietary fiber so I want to just I
wish you could see the slide but I'll
send it to you I'm going to take
broccoli for example broccoli has about
10 grams of carbohydrate okay but it has
three point eight grams of fiber so if
you - those two you end up with six
point two grams of carbohydrate not that
much so you're not going to have any
problems with eating core broccoli I'll
tell you that right now
let's take an apple an apple has 25
grams of sugar and it has four point
four grams of fiber so that means it's
20 point six grams of carbohydrate so
really you could only get away with if
you only ate like that is your
carbohydrate you're only going to get
away with maybe two and a half a Polly
a lot of people because they eat other
things and there's a little bit of
carbohydrate and cheese and nuts and
things like that the apples are going to
blow them way out a ketosis and I know I
recommend apples in my book so again
I am very willing to change my ideas
when I test out your theory so I'm not
recommending apples anymore especially
if you're trying to lose weight maybe if
you're maintaining weight you can
definitely have them but one thing I
want to talk about apples is that it has
a little just a tiny bit of fiber so
that means that 19 grams of the total 25
grams are completely sugar it's it's a
lot of sugar it's a tremendous amount of
sugar now let's get to celery all right
check how many carbohydrates are in
celery 1.2 grams and there's 0.6 grams
of fiber so we're left with point 6
grams 0.6 grams of total carbohydrates
net carbohydrates that's like a half a
gram of carb harder so in other words
you can eat a lot of celery and you know
to worry about anything there's actually
no dietary sugar in celery okay so all
right good well you guys are responsive
if you have a lot of good comments here
I'll get to those hang in there
obviously there's you know sour apples
and they're sweet apples but I think I
didn't check on the amount of sugar in
the sour apples but I'm sure it's not
that low compared to what we were going
with this okay so here's the thing
we must starve the body of sugar now
that's a constant so we're going to keep
our carbs very low the next topic we're
going to talk about is protein so
protein is needed for the raw material
for ligaments muscles tendons enzymes
hormones bones cholesterol
transportation like good embedded
cholesterol like you have high density
lipoproteins
it's basically cholesterol as a protein
shuttle that moves it around okay so the
problem with protein
is we need some but we don't want too
much and the reason for that is that too
much can trigger insulin yeah that's the
problem because we don't shut off that
much protein each day so protein is used
mainly for structural type things to
replace the damaged parts and I know
people that when they try to beef up and
want to get bigger at the gym they eat
more protein what's going to happen
we're going to strain their livers and
their kidneys so so it's not a good
advice so we want to adjust the protein
to the person to their size and their
adrenal health because the adrenal puts
a person in a called catabolic state it
breaks down protein a lot faster
especially in the quadricep muscles in
your legs and your gluttonous Maximus
which is your butt muscle so both of
those muscles can break down if you have
a lot of adrenal stress and so you need
a little bit more protein but overall
we're not doing a lot of protein I would
say anywhere between three to six ounces
of protein per meal is perfect now when
you talk about the Atkins diet they're
talking about doing a lot more protein
we're not talking about ketosis is not a
lot of protein it's a moderate amount of
protein so we're going to keep that of
the constant so we keep our carbs down
and our proteins at a constant so now
what's what's the last variable you got
it fat now I know we've been taught that
if you eat fat you get fat it's very bad
blah blah blah blah blah let me just
give you some data on what fat really
will do when you consume the right
amount the first thing that it won't do
is it will not raise your insulin
because fat is neutral with insulin so
that's one thing second thing is that
when you start consuming the right type
of fats you're going to need that to
satisfy the brain for the fat soluble
vitamins that most vegetarians and other
people are deficient
in say when you eat your vegetables even
kale you know people say why in spinach
I am kale has loaded with vitamin A
that's true but it's a precursor to
vitamin A it's not the active form you
need animal fats to get the active
available form of the fats I love
vitamins like vitamin A where do you
give vitamin A and butter grass good
butter Kerrygold butter is the best
carrots provide the precursor that
convert into the active form but you
really if your system is good you only
convert about 5% of that so it's that
you'd have to eat a lot of vegetables to
get your fats out of vitamins and so
peoples that are eating a lot of
vegetables and hardly any fat they get
they dry out the skin dries out so we
need those fats off of vitamins
one thing to help you when you eat
vegetables to get more cloud type of
vitamins out of that vegetable is to
consume fat with your vegetables like
butter very smart thing to do so the
goal of ketosis is goes beyond just
weight loss but here's what we want to
do when you get on the ketosis we want
you to not just burn the fat that you're
eating which you will but we want you to
tap into your reserves and that is the
only way you going to do it is if you
cut the carbs down okay
now you will have to adjust the amount
of fats to your activity level and there
is something of you know certain people
burn more calories and others and some
people are going to need a little bit
more fat if you're sedentary and you
have a very poor metabolism you might
not be able to have the amount of fats
of someone that by 18 but you can
definitely have some to satisfy your
body and run the Machine a lot better so
that's another variable that we have to
adjust as we go through this why do we
need fat to burn fat that's an
interesting question because first of
all the body considers fat is the last
store ditch effort of survival and so if
you cut the fat away your body will
start holding on to fat more dearly so
we start putting that that back it will
feel a lot safer to be able to let some
of it go because again it's a survival
mechanism if you have no dietary fats
you starve the body of not only the
ketones but the structural types of fats
that you need to surround it to filled
to surround all the cells of your body
to surround the nerve endings because
all your nerves are surrounded with
myelin sheath that's fat and your brain
is mostly fat so you actually starve
some of the structural fats and you end
up having a lot of health problems with
the immune system I think was pretty kin
he had a lot of health approach I think
he committed suicide I think it probably
affected his whole mood when you cut
your fats way down so it's very
dangerous to have a very low fat diet
it's much healthier to have the healthy
fats I've been doing fats for ever and I
eat consume a tremendous amount of fats
if you do a low carb low fat and
high-protein diet you will then spike
that insulin because high protein
stimulates insulin and stresses the
kidney and liver and so the person will
start feeling more bloated they'll get
back pain a little bit higher up that's
the stress on the kidney okay if you do
a low carb low fat low protein there's
not enough fats to stimulate the ketosis
and so your body because of the low
protein low fat will have a tendency to
go after structural proteins of your
body so it starts to break down more
protein so really the ideal when you
look at it from all different sides the
ideal situation is to have about very 5%
of the total calories being carbohydrate
20 to 25 percent being protein and the
rest being fat and then just have to
adjust the quantities so really eating
fat keep
the body out of stress so you don't have
those danger signals in fact think about
what sugar metabolism is eating sugar
puts your body in a state of flight or
fight mode all the time because it's a
sudden burst of quick energy that keeps
dropping your blood Sugar's up and down
up and down
that's stress because it's going to
activate cortisol that's that stress on
them okay so where do you get you know
your vitamin A vitamin D vitamin e k2
well if it divided Monnaie from the
grass-fed butter you also will get it
from the cobbler oil vitamin D from the
Sun cod liver oil again fish oils
grass-fed butter and egg yolks are
loaded with vitamin D vitamin E you can
get from butter again but you can also
get it from nuts and seeds and certain
oils now the other one I'm going to talk
about is vitamin k2 vitamin k2 is one of
the most important vitamins for a lot of
health problems specifically making your
arteries elastic so it's really good for
blood pressure it's good to make clean
out the calcium buildup in your arteries
in your joints and that's that's in
grass-fed beef butter and cheese so you
want that grass-fed cow very important I
mean it's kind of a recently discovered
vitamin but it makes sense now that
putting your body in ketosis would
naturally have you gravitate to more of
these fatty foods that have the vitamins
that you've been missing this whole time
so I always ask people that are
vegetarians I says where do you get your
vitamin k2 now you could get it from a
vegetarian source it's called NATO but
where do you get all your vitamin A and
where do you get your other fats I love
Ottomans so it's just something to
consider so it's very difficult to get
in ketosis if you're a vegetarian I have
nothing against trying to do that but
most vegetarians are granite Aryans they
do the
means and the breads in the pastas okay
so now what types of fats are healthy
that is the question
well there's the type of fats that are
low stress to the liver and don't stress
the gallbladder are the medium chain
fats medium chain triglycerides now what
does that mean that means that those
fats that you would consume like
grass-fed butter that's a medium chain
triglyceride coconut butter is a it's
called MCT medium chain triglyceride
olive oil is good grasp it cheese
pasture-raised eggs work chickens go out
there and can go and eat grass grass fed
beef pasture raised chickens those are
the ones that you're going to have to
eat believe it or not grass-fed beef has
a really good type of fat it's called a
monounsaturated fat that's bypasses your
liver and it's used just for energy I
feel really good when I do that but you
don't want to consume the lean beef you
want to have the fattier beef you don't
want to have the chicken with the skin
off you want that skin it's exactly
opposite of what we've been taught okay
so ketones provide 3 times as much
energy so you'll find that your brain is
has just has more energy you actually
need a little bit less sleep if you do
this and it's very stable in your blood
sugar so you don't get so moody so many
people have anxiety it's just your blood
Sugar's especially if they're waking up
Ludmilla night having anxiety but
ketones are only made you know I'm not
talking about diabetes ok but ketones
call it nutritional ketosis is only
occurs when the body is starving of
carbohydrates ok that's what you have to
do there's some other benefits to that
I'm going to talk about with your your
gut a lot of people get swelling in
their gut
when they have just a little bit of
fruit and beans and some other grains it
just tears them up when they start going
more fat their entire digestive system
does wonderful I'll never forget I was
living on grains trying to be a
vegetarian when I was 28 and then one
day I ate a I was in California I was
driving on the street I see this huge
building it says the health house
it says yellow building I said honey
let's go in there let's see what they
have maybe they can help me so this
old-time weightlifter guy we had those
selling vitamins and things and he
brought me in the back and he gave me
some raw milk and he said here eat this
beef whatever and that was in the
morning and I ate that I felt so
amazingly good
so I started having that for breakfast
and I do much much better and I cut the
sural out I used to be the epitome of
the junk food junkie I used to eat the
muffins huge muffins life cereal I would
do that I would live on sugar but coming
back to my point was that your gut um
can do very well on fats in fact the
microbes in your gut primarily live on
something called butyric acid and yes
that does come from the breakdown of
eating vegetables but it also comes from
butter that's the main source to feed
your microbes the other source a smaller
source of some of the future microbes
would be acetic acid and that is in the
outside of vinegar so apple cider
vinegar is a really good thing a
teaspoon in some water as you drink that
with your lemon forget the cranberry
okay but just drink that through the day
that's actually will that will really
help you in shrinking your stomach okay
so now I want to talk about beef for
example let's say a hamburger without
the bun how much how much carbohydrate
is in that hamburger zero okay how much
fat is in there 24 24 percent of
hamburgers found guess how much protein
30% so we got it's almost half fat and
half protein so when I say you need 60%
of your diet that I'm talking about a
lot of the protein sources that you're
eating have a tremendous amount of fat
already so we're not talking about
thinking that a piece of meat for
example is pure fat I'm pure protein and
you have to eat all this lard I'm not
talking about that a lot of the proteins
that you already eat are loaded with
certain percentage of fat so now there's
a study that I'm going to send you it's
called the long term effects of a
ketogenic diet and obese patients and
this is what it says this is
experimental clinical cardiology says
administration of the ketogenic diet for
relatively longer periods of time did
not produce any significant side effects
in patients and it's safe to use for a
longer periods but you know they're not
going to emit this because who wants to
be wrong right all right so I also I
wish I could show you this picture let
me see if I could do that now let's see
if that screen share no it doesn't work
okay that's fine I have these new keto
bombs I want to share with you it's an
amazing recipe in fact I will send see
if I could send that right now some of
you have already clicked on and went to
dr. Burke calm fat burning um
diets let me just see if I can let's see
if I can just sent it to you here
yeah maybe I could I think that went to
everyone let me see if I can
it's my message - OH - everyone here we
go
- everyone okay I'll paste it in there
boom okay now everyone should get this
link and you could look at this later
not right now but if you go in there and
a lot of you already went in there but I
added some new things I added these new
Kido bombs that are just amazingly
delicious and I give you the recipe and
you can make them as a base and you can
put all sorts of things in there to make
them interesting with nuts and they're
delicious and they're very very healthy
it's one of the best treats that you can
eat and I'm going through quite a few of
those little guys okay I also have in
here kind of an a general eating plan
that I'm going to recommend for you but
the other thing I want to mention is
that um yes I want to answer the
question yes it will be later available
on YouTube here's the thing that I
wanted to mention that the kale recipe
the kale shake recipe that I've been
recommending and I'm changing that
recipe um I'm actually going to put it
in a booklet and just get it out there
it'll be on my website but here's the
thing that I wanted to mention about
that is that I'm taking out the fruit
okay and I'm putting in there something
called liquid stevia okay berry flavored
with two tablespoons of coconut oil and
you blend it up I swear it tastes just
like a kale shake it's amazing and you
don't really need the berries and that
would be something you can do on a
regular basis so I have a whole week of
foods that I'm going to get to you guys
and then I have the new kale shake
recipe and how to make it and there's a
couple other things that you need to
think about when you do this ketose
eating plan one is that
some people are going to have to adapt
to ketosis and that adaptation takes
anywhere between three days to two weeks
but think about just think about it
could probably take you more than two
weeks to get into a good state because
your body has to adapt to it it has to
make new enzymes it has to produce more
bile and if you have any liver or
gallbladder issues you may need to add
bile in there and a lot of you if you
take in my gall bladder formula but I
want to let you know I change the
formula just recently so it's the new
formula I added something called
pancreatic to the gall bladder formula
so not only does it have the bile for
the gall bladder support and the stomach
enzymes but now we have the the ultimate
pancreatic enzymes especially lip base
lipase is the main enzymes to digest
lipids or fats so the reason I put that
in there is because I realize that when
people take the bile and it breaks down
the fat it doesn't break it all the way
down to the smallest level so they need
the lipase to take it all the way down
to complete full digestion so the new
gall bladder formula has all three main
component parts so it handles all parts
of the digestion so that's a kind of
something that a lot of people take when
they are doing more fats the other thing
you want to mention I think about when
you do this is that you're going to have
to increase your sea salt when you do
this because carbohydrates store so much
sugar and when you actually stop eating
them and you dump all the sugar and you
dump some of the electrolytes and if you
don't add the sea salt back into the
diet you might be a little dizzy
headachy lethargy fatigue all those
those symptoms
I also recommend doing a calcium
magnesium before bed just so you know
you can get it calcium citrate magnesia
set ranges take it before bed because
calcium magnesium is going to be a
little bit more important now that if
you're doing more
and program and no carbs unless you have
too much calcium which is probably not
the case so we want to add we want to
look at several things we want to make
sure that the minerals are in there that
we can digest some of these fats we want
to keep the constant low carbohydrate
moderate protein and higher fats but now
we're going to adjust the fats for your
tolerance for your digestion and and for
your weight loss if you are not active
obviously you're not going to have as
many fast as I do but if you're
exercising you can get away with more
fats but now that your body is getting
more in ketosis
you're not going to crave anything
anymore you're not going to be as hungry
so you're not going to have the appetite
you have before so it's going to be much
better to do this and let's say before
you go to bed just take one of those
keto snacks in your you're good to go
now what I want to do I want to answer
some questions okay so someone asked
about milk well milk is high in protein
but it has lactose so you might want to
look on the label and see how many net
carbohydrates because I don't think
there's a lot of fiber in that milk so
you you want to end up with no more than
50 net carbohydrates okay so per day so
you might want to do a little
calculation on that yes good
what is the optin what are the optimum
numbers for ketosis as far as what
numbers like when you test your urine
for ketosis um well you can get a keto
strip and urinate and see if you're in
strong ketosis or not but don't be
discouraged if you don't get into
ketosis right away it might take two
weeks or four weeks but now some people
get constipation they might need a
little bit of bile support and that's
they're in the gallbladder formula
lubricates the colon and add a little
more sea salt - add more fluid in water
so you don't dry out so that should
handle those symptoms now if you don't
have a gallbladder you definitely need
some support in the in that area because
what's where's the bile coming from it's
trickling down your liver you need
you're going to have to take vile as
extract with each meal because you don't
have enough and you won't be able to
pull in the thoughts I have item is that
you need to end up with dry skin okay
someone asks about alcohol alcohol is
out you can't do alcohol I'm sorry
because that's going to you're going to
it's going to bump you out of ketosis
for probably a good week if you're
willing to do that you can do it
now there is someone asked about kefir
there is a type of kefir that you can
use that is non lactate so that's like
no sugar lactate is milk sugar so I
think you can get away with that one of
the great rest of the ingredients in
this keto bomb is cream cheese organic
cream cheese oh my gosh it makes the
cookies so amazing eggs that depends on
your size I do four eggs and cheese in
the morning every single morning my wife
can't do more than two eggs um you can't
do it
so it really depends on how many that
you how big you are and your appetite
turkey bacon I don't recommend it cuz
it's too lean you actually need a good
source of you know bacon that has no
nitrates and hormone-free not so I'm
going to recommend unless you want to
turkey bacon just for your protein
alright so there's a lot of questions
coming in here if you're pregnant in
nursing um that's something I'm not
going to recommend online here because I
don't want to take responsibility
I think whatever do is I would check
with your doctor and see if it's okay
but just make sure that see if you take
an
infant breast milk is the ultimate
ketose diet because you're getting all
these fats an infant uses ketones and a
developing brain that's what they use
diet soda well it's better than sugar
but it's not the greatest what I do is I
take Pellegrino see this stuff right
here Pellegrino I go through these tons
of them I put about five drops of
flavored rip beer or Cola stevia and it
tastes like a soda I love it
okay so Pam asked can I skip a meal if
I'm not hungry
absolutely see this is the thing you're
going to find that your appetite is
going to go down you're not going to be
as hungry then don't eat you don't need
to I mean you don't it's not going to
actually help you and you'll do fine
because you're actually eating denser
calorie foods and you're going to have
enough nutrients that you can tap in the
more fat if you do that someone asks
about avocados wonderful wonderful fact
I love it someone asks about xylitol
that's my sugar that I have xylitol is a
great birch bark type of sweetener it's
way better than the other ones some of
the vegetarian chocolate chips use multi
top don't buy them with multi tal you
can do with mannitol if you want
I like the stevia but multi tall I don't
recommend it I don't recommend honey
either okay coffee if you have a small
amount of coffee with xylitol not any
more of that it's not going to be a big
problem
kidney disease if you have kidney
disease that's notice I'm not going to
answer that online because I'm someone's
going to say oh yeah dr. Burke that's
something like a one on one question but
I will say that people with kidney
disease do not do a lot of protein but
they do really well on some fats they do
very well in fact I would love to do a
research project for go down to local
dialysis unit and just put every
right eating plan I bet you would see
incredible things but they're not gonna
let me do that okay
so what about the adrenal well someone's
asking about the adrenal it's a really
good program for the Drina but you just
have to have a little bit more protein
okay more protein the problem with some
people if they're real have severe blood
sugar issues severe hypoglycemic they
might have the transition phase that's a
little bit too more gradual so you may
have to add maybe some fruit into that
mix for a little bit so out of all the
all you might want to mute your mic judi
out of all the sweet things okay like
there's levels of damaging sweet foods
if we have like potatoes and things like
that versus fruit fruit is much much
better even though it's sweet and the
reason for that the fructose has a
different pathway than starches and
fructose does not necessarily spike
insulin it does create fat in the liver
but it doesn't jack up the insulin as
much as some of these starches so if
someone was diabetic and they had low
blood sugar
don't take the glucose tablets take some
fruit not orange juice but actual fruit
does the diet affect hypothyroidism
adrenal fatigue it probably would
improve both conditions but hypothyroid
is usually coming secondary from
estrogen dominance or a gall bladder
liver problem
so you can create that video I mean you
can watch that video that I created on
that nutritional yeast is totally fine
because that will give you the B
vitamins that you need type 1 diabetics
need to do this it'll take the stress
off the pancreas and really help them
stabilize blood sugars the only thing
you have to do is you have to make sure
your greens are very high so in this
eating plan
well the where I get all my vitamins and
minerals is from the greens my salads
are huge okay so I'm going a lot of
green that's
but I eat the fiber I don't just juice
everything okay because that's I want
the nutrients I want some of the fiber
in there okay so these are coming
through
okay so sis dr. Greg doesn't agree with
subtracting fiber from the carbs he says
carbs are carbs well here's the thing
you don't want to just look at the net
carb you want to see if there's actual
sugars in there and you want to use
judgment obviously if it's a vegetable
you don't really have to worry about it
too much if it's some box food you do so
there are certain things that you know
that are high glycemic well just you're
going to have to avoid them make sure
that your xylitol it's a good point
Lynne is from birchbark not from corn
yeah
wheatgrass juice powder is totally fine
to consume because it's is not a lot of
sugar in that and it's a tremendous
amount of concentrated green juice that
will give you a lot of nutrition almond
butter is good unsweetened peanut butter
is good unless you have allergies now
someone says will I ever be able to eat
fruit again yeah you will once you lose
the weight then you can stick in the
fruits more as the maintenance because
you're going to be able to get away with
more carbohydrate the more you do this
because you're basically fixing your
pain tris you're fixing your liver when
you do this because you're taking all
the stress or off the pancreas has been
working so hard so it starts to come
back and we can recover it's a wonderful
thing to do for your body kombucha tea
there's you want to put the one with two
grams of sugar and make sure that you
don't have any more than that because
some of them have a lot more sugar so
you just have to look at labels
cruciferous vegetables if you can't do
those that's fine do spinach do leafy
greens it's totally fine
let me just grab this right here now
there's there's four more minutes and
she might be someone mentioned ketosis
for polycystic ovarian syndrome
absolutely it would be the thing that I
think will help you more than anything
what you guys ask a lot of questions
this is flowing through so fast
um how do you gain muscle on ketosis
well you're going to get you're going to
get leaner you're going to burn fat
you're going to you're going to well you
don't need a lot of protein to build
muscle you need exercise but you need to
keep the insulin low so you don't get
that conversion to the fatty tissue I
have lots of people who lost tremendous
amount of weights weight doing this and
they were very stubborn before and this
is what they really needed you have to
take it one step further now I want to
send everyone a link to something that I
want to I want to ask you a lot of you
are on my email list a lot of you I'll
watch my videos and you know that I give
a lot of free stuff out and I hope you
appreciate that what I'm going to ask
from you in exchange tonight is to give
me an unbiased review okay that's all I
want to exchange I want to review so I'm
going to send you a link and I'll try to
email it to to this review site and you
just type in a review tell me what your
experience with my information what you
think about me whatever and and be
honest and say wherever you want to say
but then you'll get an email probably
tomorrow morning that will tell you to
cut and paste that review on to either
Google+ or another site and I'd really
appreciate it appreciate that if you
would do that for me and I'm going to
continue to give you guys a lot of good
content but in exchange I really
appreciate if you can give me a review
so I sent you the link and you can do
that after we're done so I'm going to
thank you in advance for that now
someone just asked me a question I gotta
go back I just quickly saw that oh
you're welcome thank you neuropathy
peripheral neuropathy is purely high
sugar in the blood so when you do this
eating plan your Sugar's will be so much
better it'll take the pressure off the
destruction of the myelin sheath and it
will greatly improve the peripheral
neuropathy but you're going to have to
add nutritional use to add those B
vitamins to be able to feed the
deficiencies that you're creating by all
this insulin okay someone said but I
can't buy the Ford everything in the
world okay
well here's the thing you don't have to
spend a lot of money on a ketosis diet
you can make these keto bonds in bulk
you're not eating as much food you can
you can make the most incredible ice
cream I'm going to create some videos on
how to make some ice cream that is
totally legal and you can do that and
it's not expensive you take a whole
bunch and you freeze it so there is a
way to do it um okay how many carbs can
I have per day I would say no more than
50 carbs a day okay but don't worry
about salads
you're not you're not going to get a lot
of carbs from them but even I'm 50 and
my skin keeps getting better and better
than more I do this I do take a lot of
fat soluble vitamins use the gallbladder
formula to emulsify so I'm constantly
pushing fats into my system and I don't
I don't have like dry skin anything like
that
okay so if you didn't get the email that
I sent to everyone I'll send it one more
time but also I'll just send it to your
email um right now actually
it should be going right now so if you
don't get an email so - man
you still don't get an email do me a
favor tomorrow go to my Google+ page and
do a review on Google+ I would
appreciate that very much
so um I know I I want to keep it to one
hour I do these monthly I'm going to be
asking for more ideas to talk about but
I hope you got some tips I'll be doing
more seminars I really appreciate the
attention and all the questions and I
yes I will send you that recipe George
for ice cream and the keto bomb so I'm
going to be checking out now so I want
to thank you guys for coming out and
thank you Judy for being there to be
someone I can relay stuff back and forth
this video will be recorded on my
youtube channel which is you could find
that by typing in dr. Berg and I know
there's just you guys are just
downloaded all these questions I'm not
going to be able to get to all of them
but I want to thank you guys and have a
great evening
okay see you next time